our next guest is a rising star at just
13 years old Dylan Gilmer also known as
young Dylan first stole our hearts as
one of Ellen DeGeneres's favorite kids
back in 2016. now he stars in his own
Nickelodeon show Tyler Perry's young
Dylan it's all about a family whose
world is turned upside down when their
nephew A hip-hop mogul in training moves
in unannounced take a look
if
you said for a while now when can we uh
I don't know finally listen to it as
soon as it's finished you can download
it like everyone else
can you at least tell us what the name
of the mixtape is I still need to figure
that out you can always go with the
title I came up with
maybe mixmas
no remember and please stop texting me
that before I block you
block you and on Christmas Day Dylan and
I will team up for a slime covered
football game between the Denver Broncos
and Los Angeles Rams on Nickelodeon I'll
be calling the game while Dylan will be
working it as well like CBS Nickelodeon
is a division of Paramount Global Dylan
Gilmer what's up young Dylan yd what's
up baby how you doing
no yay
all right so listen we've been working
slime time we've also been doing the
Nickelodeon games what are you looking
forward to this year
I'm looking forward to meeting some new
players I've never met before and I'm
also looking forward to talking to you
guys of course you know reporting what's
going on in the field and I'm also
looking forward to you know Christmas
you know the Vibes are gonna be cool
it's a regular season game and you know
we're gonna be having virtual effects
you're gonna see Patrick Star it's gonna
be amazing how can I wait
yeah no doubt you mentioned the Vibes
and like you always say you know the
Vibes so as people are getting ready
there you go how do you prepare for a
game like this because it's a little bit
different right one calls on zooms
talking to players people think we're
asking X's and O's but tell the fans how
you prepare for a game like this
so I really just Channel my energy and I
get all my energy from the crowd you
know I really feel how the crowd is
feeling to be honest with you and I feel
like that helps me out a lot because the
crowd is always lit and it's always loud
in the stadium and I also Channel my
energy from you guys if you guys are
showing Good Vibes I'm here for you and
it's amazing
uh Dylan we like Good Vibes so how about
this get litty get litty your boy got a
key to the city recognize that
yes yes get litty dad that song is
coming out in January but my new song
Awesome thank you I know I was looking
at your video and I said God I was
thinking Dylan is there anything you
can't do I remember that moment on
Ellen's show when Tyler came out and
surprised you and said you're gonna have
a show of your own I'm trying to think
so when you look at your future what is
it exactly you want to do you seem to be
living your dream right now
uh yes ma'am it's it's just truly a
blessing that I'm here right now and
it's truly an honored to work with these
amazing people that I'm working with and
my future is definitely looking bright
and I have way more to come you know I
want to do I have movies shows more
shows and hopefully so you know me and
Nate got nominated for slime time for
Emmy Award so you know hopefully more
Awards and I also just want to start a
business and also just help my family
out and like be successful
I love this I love you said me and Nate
got to think so you've worked with Nate
you're working with Jermaine Dupree
another legendary Mogul Tyler Perry
certainly another legendary Mogul what
do you learn from all of these greats
Nate Tyler Jermaine
oh that's a great question because these
are a lot of legendary people and you
know what I learned is just to you know
never give up always be yourself because
if you're not being yourself you're
basically not in a comfortable position
if you're not yourself and you also just
gotta work hard and have a great
supportive system around you people you
trust around you
Nate ask him the question you ask him
about girls because I know Dylan the
girls are coming after you I know it
yeah yeah Dylan you always say you know
girls girls you get no girls or you say
that you get a lot of girls but I always
tell you what's better than having a lot
of girls is what
one girl one girl only
there you go that's all right a good one
good one good one good girl listen um
one good one yes yes yes yes I don't
want to put you on the spot on National
Television you know it's not the the
best thing to do but you are known for
rapping on the spot so I mean what can
you give us man
I could give you a few bars I could give
you a few bars all right all right look
that boy fly no Peter Pan I got a big
bag and a trip plan big waving all big
bands got me leaning back like a
kickstand oh Nick balling not a Knicks
fan ambient decks I can switch hands
raise over to the lambo got me sinking
lower than quicksand who want to put
money up better her money gonna come
already my dogs ain't never been Petty
wanna do locate that's Debbie
that's what I'm talking about ayd man
you know I'm proud of you like I always
tell you thank you for joining us and
I'll see you soon the Nickelodeon NFL
nickmas game between the Rams Broncos
will air on Nickelodeon alongside CBS
Sports coverage of the game here on CBS
and streaming on NFL plus YZ can do it
all that's my guy you really can we will
be right back